so now you can decide I'm serious about
the clothes because no way
I told you before and then giving things
that this is how I am and they're never
going to change my mind about that I'm
never gonna change my mind about it no
so why you promised me before before we
were married because I didn't know is it
that you didn't know or you didn't take
what he said seriously I don't want to
talk anymore I'm serious
I'm done okay good Nicole in my mood
continue to clash over what she wears
the fashion is giving
drama honey
[Music]
my moves religious beliefs and
essentially who Nicole is is just not
meshing I'm attacking myself to me
because you told me that's what you want
I didn't say you can stay in a way yeah
you don't want me I'm gone I'm getting
the gist that Nicole is ready to go she
just doesn't want to be the first to say
goodbye
[Music]
plus Gabe is giving all the Deeds he
shares what his first sexual experience
was like after undergoing bottom surgery
my first time I thought my penis was
gonna fall off wow that sounds like a
legit fear to me
foreign
[Laughter]
let's get into it
hey 90 day thin Stan it's Malicia Nicole
in my mood can say I love you a thousand
times I love you so much I love you okay
so much I love you I love you I love you
so much I love you but it's not gonna
change the fact that their core values
are not aligning someone is gonna have
to give up who they are to have peace in
this relationship difference Okay and
like that
see my love is so easy try
I've been in Egypt for a few days and
things have really been a struggle so
far Nicole is not adjusting well to the
conservative culture in Egypt she had
this problem when she tries to live over
there with Mahmoud before and it did not
magically disappear she's also not sure
if she made the right decision to
convert I converted to Islam before
Mahmoud and I got married
but in La I was experiencing doubts and
wondering if it's right for me and I
need to have that conversation with
Mahmoud because it's a big topic it's
very important to me but we're already
fighting and the timing needs to be
perfect for this one Nicole and
mahmoud's latest argument started after
they were discussing a potential family
business designing modest clothes for
women they fight over clothes they're
trying to make money off of clothes
clearly clothing is a huge part of their
story
so today me and Nicole going to my
uncle's house he have his own victory
for clothing I came up with this idea at
a time where I Was preparing for a trip
to Egypt and going to store the store
and then finding something that looks
like it's fully modest but then you turn
it around and the whole back is cut out
of it facts I can attest to that
sometimes I'm like why the entire back I
decided that since I have a background
in fashion design that perhaps Mahmoud
and I could start a family business
making clothes that I actually like and
that are modest I like Nicole's style I
think she'll do great at that they say
some of the best business ideas come
when you're trying to find a solution to
your own problem hopefully she sticks
with it so Nicole and Mahmoud go from
talking about their new hustle to Nicole
not wearing a hijab maybe we will sing
to a couple of hair today I'm not
covering my hair ever
okay Sweden yeah things just got serious
you can tell when their conversations
are about to take a turn for the worst
you start hearing endearing words like
sweetie at the most odd times okay
Sweden or I love you I love you too okay
my love I love you I love you too I'm
assuming it's their way of trying to
defuse the situation before it gets
superheated
I just wish it worked I'm not covering
my hair ever
okay sweetie
I guess your time about that you're
giving me my time about that it's always
just yeah you all said like you were
going to do it I will never do it again
you can say that
you can think that what is he really
trying to say Nicole says she tried to
wear hijab for a year but it was hot
extremely uncomfortable and my mood
wouldn't let her go out of the house
without it being perfect I felt like I
betrayed myself and there's honestly no
worse feeling than that
I mean I think they are beautiful like I
really do yeah I just don't like it's
really uncomfortable for me okay my love
what you can say about your window
okay my mood there is clearly a desire
to control here at the same time it's
sounding like Nicole made some promises
that she's not keeping will you promised
me before so
you have also went back on your promises
because at one point like when you first
together you decided at least when I'm
in America that I could wear I said
short sleeves yeah I said yeah yeah like
no you said like here oh and even all
the times we video chatted in the
Summers when I was in Ellie and stuff I
would have short sleeves on and you know
that yeah no you almost showed me like
oh you're wearing jacket there like you
always no that's not true
you never showed me that yes I did
Mahmoud ends up storming off
this
bad way and the call follows Mamu tells
her that he's not budging on her
covering her body and this is when you
start to see that he really took her at
her word when she made whatever promises
she made to him this is how I am and
they're never going to change my mind
about that I'm never gonna change my
mind about it no so why you promised me
before before we were married because I
didn't know this show will remind you
how important it is to know things
before you get married and always
remember don't just listen to someone
telling you who they are look at who
they're showing you they are
it's cliche but actions speak louder
than words you can hope and wish someone
changes all day but don't count on being
able to convince them
oh all the times I thought I could
convince somebody
um it's a setup for disappointment I
think we not can be together so
you can't be with me you can't be with
me but don't have me come here and like
work really hard and then just be like I
don't want to be with you because you
can't I don't want to talk anymore I'm
serious
I'm done okay good my mood seemingly
breaks up with Nicole and storms off
again
too much I'm like I can't make you happy
and this is like the most problem with
me right now
sometimes I feel like I'm not the right
person
[Music]
oh he loves her it's interesting how
rules we are taught to abide by can be
the reason we choose to be with someone
we love or not for Mahmoud and Nicole
this might be one of those situations
where
once my mood calms down and returns he
finds Nicole packing her bags and
everything changes
so are you ready to go to my office like
what's the point what's the point now
I mean you said you don't want to be
with me
okay Nicole so you don't want to do
tell me what you doing now I'm attacking
myself because you told me that's what
you want I think that's what you want
Nicole
let's get real the previous episode she
was crying in the bathroom about being
homesick and I don't blame her yes she
should have taken his religious beliefs
more seriously but at this point who
wants to be in a foreign country and
argue with the only person who is your
support system all the time and on top
of that you came to the country for that
person you can stay in weight
you don't want me I'm gone
I gave up everything I came here to be
with you and then now you say you don't
want me anymore because I won't wear the
clothes you want
wait roll it back Nicole in my opinion
that's not fair to say because it's not
that simple these clothes are attached
to his morals his beliefs beliefs he's
had since he was a child and to expect
him to change his belief system like
that
isn't realistic especially when he's
surrounded by people who share those
same beliefs now changing my mind a lot
you can be with you I know that she
changed everything can hear life but I
changed my mind about like when she
don't like pray much and don't worry God
she's all like big tears for me this is
why I was so curious here when she said
I will talk of my Hiccup and I said
don't ask for more
I'm trying to show her it's not okay for
me there are some things you can
compromise on in a relationship I'm not
a relationship expert but I'm not sure
if any of those things should be your
core values like in this case your faith
now I don't think you have to think the
exact same way when it comes to
spiritual matters as your partner but if
your beliefs are not mostly aligned how
do you expect to grow together
especially if faith is such a huge part
of your life those are my thoughts
though tell me what you think I feel
like I never come back
well I mean
I I don't know anything other than that
you told me to go so that's what I'm
going to do I never want to go on a call
did you say it don't do that like don't
make me come here and then tell me you
want me to go and then storm off and
then just leave me or do you know like
do you know what it's like a person in
Egypt do you know
stop like playing with me this is why we
never get anything done she's always
just like playing these weird little
games it's okay whatever
change whatever you want my mood starts
to try to make another exit because he
says he doesn't want to fight you want
to fight through one of we came back I'm
gonna work this out like I'm either
gonna go or I'm gonna stay but I don't
want to stay under these conditions I'm
not gonna stay with them
you are really
but after Nicole seemingly calls him out
of his name he storms off and she is
left there to figure out if she's going
to continue to pack those bags or not
next week mahmoud's family gets involved
yes
religion is very personal and it's
nobody's business why I'm not wearing
the veil anymore
foreign
go home Nicole
go home
all right let's switch gears from the
drama to the learning aspect of TLC I
quickly want to show you this moment
where Gabe and Isabelle are at dinner
and he goes into detail about bottom
surgery AKA aphaloplasty so when you
have phalloplasty you can use your arm
or you can use your leg if you use your
arm it's going to be very skinny but if
you use your leg it's going to be
thicker so right now because I used my
leg I don't feel like it has to get the
implant because it's rigid enough for
penetration
hello
[Laughter]
Isabel goes on to ask the big question
how does it work
s see
tutes
this
is because the nerves is connected
science
I'm not gonna lie a lot of this
information
it's new to me
go see
it's the same liquid that comes out of
you I have the same because I was a
female and so it's the same but it comes
out like
it takes a longer
foreign
wow
Gabe goes on to detail his first time
having sex after his surgery me primero
VES Conseco is
and Translate
my first time I thought my penis was
gonna fall off
give me
baby
so let's be pink eyes
and then he makes a public apology to
his family
um this is a lot of penis talk oh my
gosh I'm so sorry to my mom to my
grandma oh my gosh
I'm sorry family well on the bright side
you definitely educated a lot of us when
it comes to these two next week one of
Gabe's friends enters the picture and
Isabelle is not happy I'm trying to
propose to her what she's already like
really possessive today is
so you know this is usually our spot bro
where me and you hang out
I do have a problem
got your hands full buddy I guess
somebody has to bring the drama all
right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with E.T because we are covering
it all I will see you next time
[Music]
foreign